Film Courage: Does the screenwriter find themselves
an agent or does the work find them the agent?
Lee Jessup: In a perfect world, the way that
we’d love to see it work is your script
comes in as a finalist for the Nicholl [Fellowship].
Every manager and agent in town reaches out
to you.
Boom!
You have a manager or an agent, right?
You win the UCLA contest.
Very much the same scenario.
Austin Film Festival, etc.
That is not always the scenario.
The scenario for most writers is they are
going to work very hard to find a rep.
It’s usually going to be a manager first.
Because a manager really today serves as talent
scouts for the big agencies.
And it’s going to take a lot of work, a
lot of diligence and a lot of consistency
to find that rep.
So (for example) one of my writers who just
got signed a couple of months ago had this
group of managers and agents that she would
approach every time she would finish a script.
And it was vetted and she knew it was ready
to go.
She had placed in the top 3 in Final Draft
some years ago but nothing materialized rep
wise.
And so she had finished a new script she was
really excited about and we were sitting across
from one another and going through her list
and she was like [makes a sound of exasperation]
“Do I have to send a script to this manager
again?!
I’ve sent him like 5 scripts and he doesn’t
like anything.”
And I said “Yeah.
You send it to everybody.
That’s just what we do.”
And three weeks later that manager become
her manager who is now sending her out on
an insane amount of general and show runner
meetings.
Because finally the thing came aboard because
he was like “I knew you were a writer.
I knew you were good.
I know that you’re consistent.
Now you wrote something great.”
So oftentimes it ends up being the writer
finding the rep, rather than the rep finding
the writer.
Even though we’d like to think that in a
perfect world a rep would come knocking on
your door.
In truth, it’s a referral business.
So the best reps and the best relationships
are forged through referrals.
Where somebody will say “Hey, my friend
Joe just finished this great script.
You should read it.”
Because really that’s what the industry
trusts.
We’re a highly social industry.
So if you can get those referrals which is
why you foster relationships, those are priceless.
It’s much easier to get a rep through a
referral than a contest placement unless you’re
winning that contest.
Or through the Blacklist, unless you get the
coveted 9 rated on the Blacklist.
So really it’s about working those relationships
so those referrals will be in place when you
have that script that’s ready to share.
Question for the Viewers: Without naming names,
share how a writer you know found an agent.